oh my god
hey out there everyone welcome in
welcome welcome to another edition of
market takes i am your host dion robon
reporter at the wall street journal
thank you so much for being with us i
know you could have been anywhere in the
world but you're here with me and i
appreciate that look today we are diving
deep jumping all the way into today's
u.s retail sales report for july we are
going to be unpacking that report and
talking all about the latest big piece
of data on the u.s economy we're going
to be talking about the headline number
on that retail sales report how that
report stacked up to expectations uh
really how the squares with the new
confidence that we're seeing on wall
street kind of a clot across asset
classes about this new expected soft
landing for the u.s economy that was
very much in doubt just a month or two
ago back in june now it seems like
markets are pricing in that soft landing
which means continued economic growth
which means lower inflation which means
the fed really is likely to be able to
accomplish what they're trying to do
which is raise rates to curb inflation
while also
not seeing a big pickup in unemployment
or a crash in the economy that would be
a hard landing uh we're going to talk
about how today's report could affect
the market and what it tells us about
the third quarter and what it tells us
about the fourth quarter uh going
forward as we as we look forward and
don't look back maybe we're done with
all that so listen let's jump right into
it the headline number on this july
retail sales report zero percent uh
month over month gain on retail sales um
that is flat versus expectations for a
0.2 percent gain so we missed
expectations but only by a little bit
and we're up 10
from where we were in july 2021 so
retail sales continuing to look strong
uh folks continuing to go out and spend
and buy but
the devil is in the details on this
report so we're going to get into all
those listen weakness was expected
coming in we weren't expecting a big
blowout number on this retail sales
report and we certainly obviously didn't
get it right zero percent uh change but
remember in july inflation was always
also 0.0 percent from the previous month
so we got a reading that's right in line
with that cpi inflation report that we
got for july as well uh this is a big
step down from the one percent gain that
we saw in june but that number was also
revised lower today so june being
revised from one percent gain to zero
point eight percent gain uh so you're
just seeing kind of a general come down
on the retail sales number it's it's not
falling off a cliff it's not dropping
into negative territory but you're
seeing a kind of stall out and if you
look at the overall trend year over year
you're seeing this kind of flattening
trend very clearly the report is showing
retail sales are kind of flattening look
the big thing about this report was the
major drag was gasoline if you take
gasoline sales gas prices out of this
well the numbers look a lot stronger
and that again matches up with what we
saw for cpi for july sales excluding
autos and gas were up 0.7
that beat expectations
and you also saw gasoline stations were
the biggest drawdown the biggest uh
thing pulling the report back gasoline
station sales were down about two
percent this month um worse than
expectations motor vehicles and parts
were next
down about 1.6
so really what that tells you is the
declines that we're seeing the things
really dragging back and pulling back
retail sales are the auto sector the
gasoline sector all things related to
that those are the things that have
really taken off and boomed over the
course of much of this year or over the
course of much of last year that we're
seeing really kind of moderate economy
is generally holding up so that's not
necessarily a bad thing that's not
something that people should be worried
about and in fact if this trend
continues if gas prices continue to come
down
that's going to be a headwind or sorry
it's going to be a tailwind for the
economy for the rest of the year
the other big piece of this was that
retail sales the control group right the
control group was stronger than
anticipated that excludes food services
automobile dealerships building
materials and gasoline stations so that
number was up about almost one percent
and so again continuing if you take gas
out of this out of the equation you're
seeing continued pickup in sales you're
seeing continued strength from the
consumer and these are all good things
as we look out at the economy nine of
the 13 pieces of this retail sales
report were higher on the month of the
best was non-store retailers that got a
big boost from amazon prime day which
happened in july uh that's definitely
something that folks you know you wanna
you wanna write that out that's one of
these kind of
exogenous events it's not something you
can count on each month so we're
interesting to see how non-store
retailers can perform as we move
throughout the year
non-store retailers up about 20 percent
from july 2021 so that again is a
category that has showed continued
strength for a while
over the course of the year now
let's put this retail sales report in
context right nothing nothing exists in
a vacuum in a bubble alone unto itself
we are seeing the housing market in
recession so
the national association of home
builders came out earlier this week and
told us we're seeing the housing market
in recession you had a reading of 49
below that marker of 50 which you know
is the difference between expansion and
contraction you had a 49 reading on the
nahb
home building sentiment index
earlier this week that tells us the
housing market which we've known for a
while right we've seen consistent
declines in existing home sales in new
home sales and pending home sales and
we've continued to see that
and so we're now seeing what nahb calls
a housing recession that's going to have
some knock-on effects throughout the
economy and something you want to keep
your eye on not just for what it says
about the housing market folks buying a
house but for what it does to rents
owner equivalent rents cpi all those
things moving forward
the empire manufacturing service that's
basically the new york state region the
federal reserve the the country is is
divided into about 12 regions by the
federal reserve one of those is the
empire or the new york state region that
was down
31.3 a negative 31.3 reading in august
that's a 42 point decline from the
previous month that is a huge drop off
the second largest decline in history
normally those fed regional
manufacturing surveys don't make a big
dent on impre on investor screens this
is definitely one to watch that happened
earlier this week so you might start to
see a a an increased pickup in the
decline in some of those manufacturing
numbers definitely something to look out
for like i talked about housing again
housing starts were down 10 in july
single-family housing was down 18.5
multi-family housing up 18
what does that tell you it tells you
individuals families not going out and
buying houses developers investors uh
those big money private equity funds and
things like that they're continuing to
buy and continuing to invest in the
housing market we'll see how that winds
up we also saw another decline in
mortgage applications
just this morning from the mortgage
brokers association the mortgage bankers
association excuse me uh so again we're
seeing more weakness in the housing
market and that could have more of these
knock-on effects
housing spending
it's one of those things that doesn't
just impact housing prices like i said
you see this in retail and home
furnishings you see this in places like
target walmart lowe's home depot because
if you're not buying a new house well
you're not buying things to furnish that
house or to make improvements or repairs
on that house and so that kind of can
have a snowball effect throughout the
economy general merchandise sales and
clothing sales were both were the next
two biggest lagers on the month third
and fourth third and fourth weakest
categories that we saw
for this retail sales report so again
something to watch out for as we look
forward
remember though as we saw as we're
seeing this decline in housing decline
in gas prices we are seeing a decline in
cpi and ppi the consumer price index
producer price index that's what
consumers are paying you and i we go to
the store as well as what those
businesses are paying when they buy
those goods to sell them to us that ppi
report producer prices has been a bit of
a harbinger of what's to come and so you
can really start to expect there's
reason to have optimism that inflation
could be starting to see a secular
decline here and we could consistently
start to move lower that's what you want
to see you want to see those price
increases slowing down on a consistent
basis moving forward
and we're seeing more signs of that so
price is flat that's telling us this
retail sales report that u.s consumers
are keeping up with the overall trend in
inflation not working against what the
federal reserve is doing raising rates
and making things more expensive in the
economy so we have some consistency
there um one thing that i wanted to
highlight was a report from james
knightley he is the chief international
economist at ing he had a really
interesting report that came out last
night i want to read a couple short
passages from that because he's worried
okay q3 looks like it's going to hold up
we're going to see strong economic
growth in the third quarter in contrast
to that weak growth that we've seen
through the first and second quarter but
what about the fourth quarter well he
says we strongly suspect consumer
spending will be lifted by the cash flow
boost caused by the plunge in gasoline
prices and decent employment gains trade
will be supportive too
inventory is less of a drag and now that
we know that manufacturing is rebounding
putting this all together he's expecting
three percent growth in the third
quarter so
versus the third quarter of 2021 they
say that's firmly in the cards the worry
is what happens in the fourth quarter
and he says we're closely looking to see
if this decline that we saw in the
empire state report which again the
second biggest drop on record is
replicated in the philadelphia federal
reserve report we get that thursday and
the richmond fed report will get that
wednesday as well as others later this
month uh even if it's an aberration
there are reasons to expect weaker
activity as we move forward into the
fourth quarter you've got a china
slowdown a likely recession in europe
and those are going to weigh heavily on
the global economy which again
reverberates into the us and is
something that we really can't get out
of and of course he points out the
housing market he says it will also act
as a major headwind definitely something
to keep in mind look let's check out the
the market right now and the market
reaction we're seeing broadly negative
you've got the nasdaq down about one
percent the smp down about half of that
and i'm sorry the dow down about half
that and the s p down by about 0.7
percent uh let's look at the bond market
because i think that's going to really
tell us what we need to be looking at
you're seeing yields bond yields up kind
of across the board uh more pronounced
at the shorter end of the curve than the
longer end of the curve which basically
tells us that the market is not pricing
in more inflation that you're seeing
that long-term inflationary outlook kind
of brought in just a little bit as
yields rise and bond prices fall kind of
across the yield curve um as we look out
at currencies right now you're seeing
euro up you're seeing the dollar up
against the yen
you're seeing the swiss franc canadian
dollar
a lot of these things rising right now
the overall thing that we've seen is
dollar strength coming off the board
over the past couple weeks we're seeing
the dollar lower it is a little bit
higher today it's up about 0.2 percent
even as the euro is up so that tells you
that against other currencies the dollar
is moving higher um a big reason that
we're seeing i think a lot of that
weakness in the stock market that we're
seeing right now and the the moves in
the bond market
is this uk inflation report that we got
this morning we got a couple different
reports on inflation from the united
kingdom the their version of the cpi the
consumer price index up 10.1 percent
year over year that was stronger than
expected and a new multi-decade high
over there in the uk uh uk producer
prices their ppi and cpi come out on the
same day that rose 1.6 percent of the
month and 17
on the year that was above expectations
also in the market we're seeing target
having a much weaker than expected
quarter prices or their profits declined
by about 90 percent as it slash prices
to get rid of a glut of inventory we've
known for a while that inventories have
been a problem however target maintained
its outlook for the whole year so again
that's a good sign for the long term
right now the short term not looking so
great so look let's step back let's take
a step back what did we learn today from
this retail sales report well we learned
that consumer buying has continued we
learned that gasoline is coming down
that sales of gas are dragging down the
overall increases that we saw if you
strip out gasoline if you strip out the
auto sector two things that boomed and
shot up very high in price
last year and early into this year well
those are coming down prices are coming
down there and overall as you look out
at the retail sales landscape consumers
still buying still going out spending
money you're not seeing a significant
pullback except in those gas and auto
sectors
that's a big thing
we know that the market did not like the
jobs report which was very strong for
july
we're seeing really a continuation of
trends inflation coming down uh jobs
continue to be strong and consumers
continue to spend as gas prices go down
this is probably not going to change the
market's mind right now about the
bullish theme of a soft landing the
retail sales report today really tells
us all right you know what not too hot
not too cold this is just about right it
doesn't change the narrative even though
we are seeing some weakness in the stock
market right now
you could expect that to reverse course
because we did not see a break in the
trend from this report so again that's
what's holding up here's what to look
out for next today later today at 2 pm
eastern time
right here we are going to get the fomc
minutes the minutes from the fed's
latest meeting or from its july meeting
uh that's the the the word that we're
getting on you know the the official
minutes from that meeting we'll get
those later today at 2pm uh markets eyes
will be very closely watching that and
that could tell us a lot about what's to
come for september what their
expectations are again the fed has kind
of moved from forward guidance to data
dependent saying hey what the data tells
us that's how we're going to react the
data we got today didn't tell us that
much has changed on the overall theme uh
we get the producer con producer i'm
sorry personal consumption expenditures
report that's the fed's favorite measure
of inflation that's coming out next week
and we will also get the university of
michigan's consumer sentiment report
next week on friday we are going to be
doing another live stream on that so
please tune in make sure you don't miss
that that's going to be a big report
because consumer confidence consumer
sentiment is the next big frontier that
could change the trajectory of the
market or really reinforce the bullish
soft landing narrative that we've got
right now so we'll be unpacking all that
next week uh listen that's going to do
it for us here on market takes i
appreciate you joining me i am dion
rabone reporter for the wall street
journal thank you for being with me on
this edition and join us next week when
we unpack the consumer confidence index
or consumer sentiment index from the
university of michigan next friday all
right thank you for joining us we'll be
back next week i hope to see you there